Guten morgen tim good morning tim.
Also als fünfundachtzig ein boris in london gewonnen hat war die zeit danach teilweise schwer zu ertragen aber ich hab's gefühl diesmal wird's noch schlimmer.
Hoffentlich endete genauso.
Buch netz politik nummer drei null neun dreihundert neun und was haben wir heute den fünfundzwanzigsten juli zweitausendundneunzehn jaja england.
Also man muss dazu sagen tim und ich spreche diese interesse in der regel tatsächlich nicht ab und es war jetzt eigentlich abgesprochen und ich wirklich ein bisschen sprachlos irgendwie boris becker und boris johnson beide so.
So lava packen.
Also es ist so.
Der brexit ne bin ich jetzt raus.
Schon raus.
Oh
Komm mal kurz komm oh mann.
Die älteren von euch erinnern sich an diese ganzen cds eigentlich inzwischen mal recycelt oder so.
Bestimmt irgendwelche kunstprojekte damit aber ich hab 's nicht mitbekommen.
Ja das war prägend damals als irgendwie diese scheiben verteilt haben und das war dann sozusagen der zugang für viele leute der erst zugang zum internet muss man mal sagen das war natürlich für das damals wirklich ein harter schlag.
Aber ja alles kalt vergleich mit dem was jetzt droht irgendwie also ich bleib ja dafür vor bei meiner these.
Aber es sieht schwer danach aus bevor es besser wird wird's nochmal richtig scheiße.
Also das ist einfach nicht schön was da gerade und statten geht jetzt halt die angelsächsischen welt ist sozusagen aus den angeln sachsen und.
Neuseeland und karl das geht noch australien ist schon immer so ein wackelt kandidat aber gott sei dank so unwichtig und britannien und usa.
Ja klonen sich jetzt gegenseitig in idiot y hast dir und sprach sie.
Ich hörte boris johnson wohl jetzt.
Was denn wenn man das mal wusste wasser.
Zum großartigsten land machen.
Ja naja das wird also hatten wir das wir nee wir hatten das nur so besprochen diese die these vom desaster capitalized.
Dass die ganze idee des brexits ist einfach das land an an den.
An die an den rand des ruinen s zu führen damit günstig alles gekauft werden kann und das dann als eine wenn dann die schöne.
Frohe kunde kommt dass die queen den spinner doch nicht vereidigt arme freude muss auch eine ganze menge mitmachen die queen ist echt ein sehr hund.
Die hat schon mehr gehen sehen als kommen und.
Die sagt sich außer kommen.
Erlebe ich auch noch.
Auf.
Der möchte gerne.
Ja ja es ist erstaunlich die hat echt hart zu leiden ich meine nicht dass ich jetzt groß mitleid mit dir hätte aber mit england kann man wirklich schon mitleid haben also ich meine stell dir mal vor du bist so eine halbwegs gebildeter aufgeklärte weltoffener mensch und wohnst da.
Und bis daher.
Ja oder stell dir vor du wohnst in deutschland oder in usa oder irgendwo stell dir vor du bist auf dem planeten erde gefangen.
Oh jetzt wird's aber hart.
Und deine einzige hoffnung ist irgendwie.
Elektronischen daumen zu nehmen und es nächste woche raumschiff zu ändern
ja naja also ganz so fantastisch wenn ich da jetzt nicht rangehen aber ist halt gerade nicht so schön ich meine u s a r verfolgen wir das ja schon seit längerem wie die leute immer total gestresst so auf dem kongress ausschlagen sagen so
endlich mal kurz in freiheit das wird jetzt da auch genauso laufen.
Wenn sie da noch rauskommen also erstmal machen wir die grenzen hier zu.
Und gucken gucken wie lange aushalten.
Weißt du wenn die briten alle im kanal springen dann werden die auch erstmal alle dürfen sie auch nicht mehr gerettet.
Komm ein bisschen drauf an ne.
Gut dass wir wenigstens amüsant ist feedback auf unsere sendung bekommen wo wir eigentlich nichts nichts wirklich angenehmes erzählen.
Und da haben wir in den letzten sendungen habe ich,
andre einen kommentar von andre vorgelesen habe gesagt klar andere meister korrigiert hier noch an der stelle weil er hat ja auch seinen masterarbeit.
Über diese gesamte angelegenheit ursula von der leyen nett sperren zensur solar geschrieben
und da kommentiert andre in klammern haar nicht m eine kleine korrektur zum feedback hätte ich noch loszuwerden,
und zwar stammte der zensur kommentar zur letzten folge von mir und offenbar hat linus mich mit andre meister von netzwerk verwechselt der bin ich nicht nur ein politisch
interessierten zuschauer der manchmal etwas nachtragen ist,
denn dieses bis hin zu urheberrechtsverletzungen habe ich mir bewusst gemerkt,
auch bei bürotür bär ja das stimmt andere meister kam auch direkt zu mir und sagte,
reingefallen aber er hat auch zugegeben der kommentar hätte auch von ihm sein können das nehme ich dann jetzt hier als.
Als lob für,
andre der auf twitter auch darauf hingewiesen hat ist es nämlich andre heinrichs vom von kompost.
Dann sagen wir einfach jetzt immer andrea und m und dann haben wir's.
Ja ich glaube,
ich weiß es gar nicht ob's in kasachstan ha und m gibt um hier direkt mit der mit der überleitung zu grätschen es gibt aber seit länger seit mehreren jahren in kasachstan bestrebungen.
Eine i'm infrastruktur aufzubauen.
Ich weiß ich weiß das heißt man in der mitte.
Und jetzt muss ich sagen nein das hieß früher männer der mittel inzwischen heißt das maschine in der mittel.
Oh ist das jetzt so eine feministische anpassung oder hat man sich.
Schneller anpassung.
Maschine fassung man hat sich sozusagen der realität gestellt das ist ja dann doch computer sind die dazwischen.
Genau es sind computer keine keine menschen.
Keine männer wir wollen keine männer in unserer mitte nein verschiedene mittel schreibt schreibt man jetzt so ein s m ist für diejenigen die.
Sich da liegt nichts neues angewöhnt wollen.
Oh da muss jetzt aber auch nochmal ran.
Ja klasse.
Move on.
Genau.
Der morgen ist schon ganz schön lang.
Wir müssen jetzt nochmal vielleicht ganz kurz erklären worum es hier geht ich versuche das technisch kurz zu fassen wenn.
Maschinen verschlüsseln.
Oder wir zwischen einander unsere nachrichten verschlüsseln verschlüsseln ist einfach sicherzustellen dass man mit der richtigen person verschlüsselt ist ungleich schwieriger
ja also wenn wir jetzt über eine wenn tim jetzt in australien wäre und ich in deutschland und wir wollen irgendwie eine,
verschlüsselte verbindungen herstellen dann brauchen wir irgendwie eine möglichkeit uns zumindest initial zu vertrauen um
unsere verschlüsselung auszuhandeln um also zu sagen okay mit welchem schlüssel verschlüsseln wir jetzt diese session oder so ne wir können nicht ohne,
irgendein vorwissen oder eine dritte vertrauens instanz aus.
Aus der distanz eine verschlüsselte verbindung aufbauen weil wir nicht wüssten ob wir mit der richtigen person sprechen.
Und dieses problem.
Kann man auf verschiedene möglichkeiten lösen in dem was ihr als web kennt wird es grundsätzlich als,
auf eine weise gelöst wo eine dritte instanz
dafür birgt dass ihr mit der richtigen kommunikations- partnerin spricht das könnt ihr sehen wenn ihr in euren browser oben auf das schloss klickt dann steht dort was weiß ich ihr sprecht mit
was weiß ich wo kommt mit der bank und,
dafür dass ihr tatsächlich mit der s-bahn gerade spricht birgt eine dritte instanz der tim macht das hier gerade mal kurz vor in unserem fall nämlich wir lassen uns das zertifikat einblenden das zertifikat ist von,
dj t-shirt letztendlich unterschrieben,
das heißt die das unternehmen die zertifikate bürgt dafür dass dieses zertifikat dort von,
tatsächlich von der ist.
Und deswegen haben wir das grüne häkchen dieses zertifikat ist gültig und vertrauenswürdig jetzt stellt sich natürlich die frage warum vertrauen wir,
wir vertrauen djs hört weil es ist eine der großen größten zertifikat ist die im prinzip nach meiner kenntnis in allen,
browser die wir so verwenden vorinstalliert ist da gibt es eine lange liste an zertifikate denen eure browser,
trauen egal ob das jetzt firefox safari oder chrome oder gibt es noch von microsoft im browser.
Ja glaube ich.
Scheiße ist ungefähr auch in so einem zustand wie.
Ja es ist eher so.
Okay,
so geht das nicht weiter so wenn nun.
Ähm ich hier in teams netzwerk rum basteln würde und versuchen würde mich zwischen tim und die bank zu setzen und seinen traffic mit zuschneiden,
zu manipulieren die verschlüsselung zu knacken dann würde ich das im zweifelsfall im rahmen,
oder durch eine maschine in dem mittel attacke machen ich würde versuchen dass der tim sich mit mir verbindet würde mich als gls bank,
ausgeben und würde vielleicht auf dem anderen ende mich sein traffic zur bank weiterleiten das wird mir nicht gelingen weil ich kein gültiges zertifikat für de präsentieren kann.
Gültig in dem fall wo mir eine dritte instanz die schon als vertrauen vor installiert ist im browser bescheinigt dass ich das auch tatsächlich bin.
Was dann passieren würde wenn ich das nun irgendwie mit einem selbst ausgedacht ein zertifikat ohne signatur von einer
akzeptiert machen würde dann bekäme der tim die klassische warnung achtung diese verbindung ist nicht sicher,
und inzwischen sind browser da sehr viel strenger früher wurde dann einfach beigebracht dass man schnell auf den knopf klicken muss um das wegzumachen diese warnung inzwischen sind browser
einfach weil es auch sehr viel mehr zertifikat hygiene jetzt im netz gibt dass sie quasi so weit gehen und sagen okay du musst ein administrator passwort eingeben um hier überhaupt weiter zu dürfen oder sowas oder das geht einfach grundsätzlich nicht mehr,
das ist ein fundamentaler sicherheits- anker unseres internets der eigentlich nur dadurch geschwächt ist dass wir so vielen pcs in unserem browser vertrauen was.
In situationen in denen böse menschen.
Oder maschinen zwischen uns und unserem vertrauens und unserem gewünschten kommunikations- partner sind.
Dann ein problem sein kann wenn wir zum beispiel in wenn wir da mit anderen länder,
zu tun haben ja also beispielsweise sind natürlich auch.
Ähm sagen wir mal von bestimmten staaten zertifikate vor installiert die wo wir jetzt nicht unbedingt das vertrauen hätten,
dass sie diese zertifikate nicht missbrauchen sagen wir mal so was wie,
institution der die den us-regierung sehr nahe stehen oder sonstigen die also diese zertifikate dann wenn es ein zertifikat ist,
nutzen können um für die echtheit jeder anderen seite die wir besuchen zu bürgen.
Deswegen solltet ihr euch unter keinen umständen,
irgendwelche zertifikate installieren wenn euch jemand sagt hier zertifikat installieren mal außer ist es irgendwie euer eigenes,
sweet zertifikat oder zertifikat oder so jede einzelne dieser unter jedes einzelne dieser unternehmen die dort vorinstalliert sind,
dem vertraut ihr letztendlich vollständig und tim hat gerade eine.
Seite auf wo steht beim mozilla wären es einhundertvierundfünfzig.
Hier schon mehrere einträge dabei.
Ja die haben relativ viele ne.
Aber die also es gibt da noch diese intermediate zertifikate also gibt dann halt nochmal anderen welche aus oder so ich denke
es ist jetzt erstmal grob erklärt eine schöne lösung war dafür letzten crypt die hatten auch ein intermediate zertifikat ich,
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob die inzwischen eigene csa sind oder immer noch ich glaube schon ne haben wir glaube ich immer berichtet.
So also was ihr euch merken müsst ist es ist nicht so einfach sich zwischen einer hd ps verbindung zu schalten die voraussetzung dafür dass erfolgreich zu tun,
ist dass eine,
im browser als vertrauenswürdig entweder vorinstalliert oder nachträglich von der nutzerinnen hinzugefügt zertifikat für die echtheit des präsentierten zertifikate auf der anderen seite birgt,
und dieses vertrauen ist in unseren browser oder in unserem betriebssystem vor installiert wir können aber auch unsere eigenen zertifikate noch mit einbauen.
Das tun zum beispiel unternehmen,
die sorge haben was weiß ich das irgendwelche über verschlüsselte verbindungen irgendwelche malu heruntergeladen wird oder das über verschlüsselte verbindungen liegst aus dem unternehmen passieren ist also eine,
leider sehr gängige unartig das unternehmen.
Effektiv mangelnde maschinen mittelstand trifft auf ihre angestellten vornehmen und das seht ihr dann zum beispiel wenn ihr irgendwie eine seite,
auf aufruf von eurem arbeitsgerät und dann auf dieses,
ding klickt und am ende der zertifikat kette steckt euer arbeitgeber dann seht ihr hier.
Findet ein mann in der mittel maschinen statt gekriegt.
Sehr elegant gerade so irgendwie.
Was hat das ganze mit kasachstan zu tun nun kasachstan hat sich entschieden wir wollen nicht wir wollen i am haben kasachstan in der mittel
und haben schon zwanzig zwölf begonnen mozilla aufzufordern sie sollten doch bitte ein staatliches ruhe- zertifikat in firefox aufnehmen die firefox entwickler drin haben gesagt ja ne,
das machen wir nur bei vertrauens würdigen institutionen und wir,
haben kennen berichtet dass ihr maschine die mittel angriffe schon in der vergangenheit versucht hab vorzunehmen und.
Zwanzig fünfzehn haben sie dann nochmal versucht
profi dann ein staatliches zertifikat aufzuzwingen mithilfe eines gesetzes wo sie also gesagt haben es gibt jetzt das sicherheits zertifikat des des staates kasachstan das muss einfach von provider banken und ausländischen
also von provider und banken genutzt werden und dann haben wir aber die betroffenen dagegen geklagt und seitdem ist die rechtliche,
lage eigentlich unklar.
Aber sachliche internet provider fordern jetzt ihre kunden auf ein zertifikat zu installieren so dass die regierung den internet verkehr mitlesen kann.
So und jetzt stellt sich die die sehr spannende frage für die firefox community was machen wir sie hätten mehrere optionen sie könnten sagen naja wir,
akzeptieren dieses zertifikat nicht und wir bauen unseren firefox browser so dass man dieses zertifikat auch nicht installieren kann,
das ergebnis wäre dann das in dem fall dass dieses zertifikat für einen maschinen mittel angriff zur anwendung kommt.
Der browser eine fehlermeldung gibt und entweder die nutzerinnen die fehlermeldung wegklicken kann oder.
Sie nicht wegklicken kann das heißt die person wäre dann vom,
internet abgeschlossen die andere option wäre das firefox sagt naja okay selbstverständlich installieren wir dieses zertifikat nicht von grund auf,
aber wir verhindern menschen auch nicht daran,
dieses zertifikat zu installieren wie sie es in unternehmen in und was weiß ich auch für eigene verwendung mein ich habe teilweise für interne systeme eine eigene wo ich dann also auch meine rucola in den browser drin habe damit ich,
agb's verbindungen in bereiche aufbauen kann in denen ich keine nicht ohne weiteres letzte zertifikate verwenden kann oder so ne also.
Und das wurde jetzt natürlich relativ viel diskutiert und was ich spannend oder was interessant ist wenn.
Dieses zertifikat nicht installiert ist dann bleibt einer betroffenen personen in der regel.
Nur die nutzung eines anderen internetanschluss ist wo das vielleicht nicht stattfindet.
Oder der abbruch der verbindung denn das sind die eigentlich die optionen die du hast denn wenn ein maschinen melange stattfindet dann kannst du den nicht.
Verhindern,
so also du die der staat ist ja zwischen dir und deinem ziel es gibt was was ich von mir aus drei kabel die aus kasachstan rausgehen wenn auf allen
diesen verbindungen diese diese wm set abläuft dann hast du keinen sicheren weg mehr nach draußen.
Und das ist natürlich schwierig,
was würde ich als keine sache machen ich würde wahrscheinlich dieses zertifikat nicht installieren damit ich wenigstens die wahl,
oder wenn die verbindung versucht wird zu knacken wenn sie es aber bei allen verbindungen machen wo ich mir nicht sicher bin ob sie das hinkriegen andererseits wohnen in kasachstan auch nicht so viele menschen.
Also das heißt die bandbreite des landes ist unter umständen.
Inzwischen im vollständig baren rahmen das kann ich leider nicht persönlich nicht so genau abschätzen gerade.
Einwohnerzahl achtzehn komma drei neun fünf millionen.
Das wird doch ein bisschen schwierig nicht unmöglich aber.
Nicht alle internet.
Wir haben nicht alle internet haben vielleicht auch nicht alle so schnelles internet.
Müssen wir nochmal müssen wir bei unserer freunde im im netzwerk infrastruktur bereich fragen wie viel.
Schneller als bei uns ist bestimmt.
Das ist das ist der fundamentaler angriff.
Auf verschlüsselung der ist noch das ist sogar also das ist,
auf eine gewisse weise wir können nun man könnte sich jetzt zurückziehen und sagen ok dann machen wir halt ende zu ende verschlüsselten kram über diese über diese browser verbindung das würde natürlich irgendwie wieder gehen
ne aber in dem moment wo sie in die verschlüsselten verbindungen reinschauen können haben sie auch wieder alle möglichkeiten der zensur,
verhinderung von verbindungen
um lenkung von verbindung kommt vollständige überwachung ne also sie zwingen alle und verschlüsselt in verbindung wieder in eine komplette klartext verbindung mit manipulation möglichkeiten mit überwachungs möglichkeit mit mit schneiden möglichkeiten mit einem und das ist wirklich der das also.
Dann könntet ihr kein banking mehr machen also könnt ihr schon aber müsstet eben damit rechnen dass ähm die katalanische regierung da alles mit.
Ja so ach so ach so ach so sieht es war nur eine spende an die partei.
Muss ja nicht mehr alles stimmen was dann da kommt so geht ja nicht nur ums mitlesen geht ja auch ums manipulieren.
Also es gibt ja auch so diesen sport
der solange hatte p ohne verschlüsselung noch da war sowieso mobilfunk dienste der dann einfach mal irgendwelche
werbung ausgetauscht haben in webseiten um da sozusagen selber geld zu machen oder affiliate links ausgetauscht haben irgendwie die kohle abzugreifen alles mögliche es gibt sehr viele gute gründe warum man sozusagen generell nicht und verschlüsselt unterwegs sein will im web
das ist jetzt nur eine kleine.
Einer der in dem zusammenhang noch sehr wichtigen gründe ist das ein
doch nennenswert großer anteil der software-updates die unsere rechner so installieren sich auf diese p s zertifikate konzentriert ja und,
das wäre natürlich dann auch eine sehr einfache lösung wenn jetzt ihr eine software verwendet die sagt okay ich begnügen mich damit dass ich das zertifikat geprüft habe und über eine sichere verbindung mein update runterlade,
und kasachstan sagt ach wir haben ja auch noch ein schönes update für dein was weiß ich welches hoffe das jetzt sein mag ne.
Wobei ordentliche betriebssysteme halt jetzt nicht nur prüfen ob ein zertifikat formal richtig ist sondern erstens.
Training haben.
Kurzzeitig haben nochmal verschüttet haben oder auch so ein zertifikat piening durchführen also wenn du sozusagen auf der anderen seite so 'ne app ist die aktualisiert war ist dass die dann sozusagen auch weiß welches zertifikat da kommen soll.
Genau die was macht die app die berichten die verbindung ab herzlichen glückwunsch dein system kriegt keine updates mehr du bist also gefangen in einer welt ohne ohne sicherheitsabstandes für deine schrott software,
es gibt eine reihe andere wege software-updates abzusichern im im lennox kontext werden die viel einfach über runtergeladen weil sie einfach noch mal,
quasi oft seid signiert werden da liegt dann einfach sie wollen sich diesen ganzen hat der gps traffic sparen das heißt die.
Es gibt einfach 'ne an den dateien eine signatur kette und nicht in dem in dem traffic,
aber durchaus auch eine reihe an software die davon halt betroffen wäre.
Das ist eigentlich echt erstaunlich dass so ein scheiß überhaupt.
Auf auf auf dem land auf diesem planeten zwanzig neunzehn noch diskutiert und dann sogar durchgeführt wird.
Ja was ist jetzt das mach ich jetzt mal museum also.
Ich gehe davon aus dass sie letztendlich nichts machen werden denn museum also firefox ist ja eh ein open source browser das heißt würden sie jetzt eine funktion einbauen,
die irgendwie das,
sache zertifikat black listet dann wäre die würdest du zwei dingen führen a die leute könnten.
In kasachstan diesen browser nicht mehr verwenden das heißt.
Marktanteil sinkt die würden in die hände von google browser getrieben was jetzt auch nicht so viel so viel besser wäre für sie oder welche.
Die denn das installiert.
Die andere frage ist könnt würde unter umständen weiterhin einfach vielleicht ein firefox fork entstehen,
wo dieser dass die tatsache schräg und sagt ja wir kriegten firefox von uns bei dem paketchen wir diese funktion wieder raus das sind ja nur wenige zeilen würden die die update zyklen von von mozilla hinkriegen,
weiß man nicht also vermute ich,
dass sie sich auf eine irgendwie eindrucksvolle warnung zurückziehen werden und sagen wir.
Lassen die funktionsfähigkeit des browser s erhalten wir aber wir werden.
Bei der verwendung dieses zertifikaten des oder von mir aus auch anderen selbst installieren zertifikaten nochmal oben,
'n totenkopf anzeigen oder so um zu sagen hier wenn du hier was falsches ein tipps kommen die schergen ne also irgendwie sowas denke ich
würde ich erwarten als reaktion was ich nicht vermute ist dass er das zertifikat vollständig black listen weil damit würden sich letztendlich von dem markt kegeln,
und hätten damit auch ihre wirkt möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft ne das ist ja immer so das.
In solchen situationen das bittere ne wenn sie das spiel jetzt irgendwie auch nur im entferntesten mitspielen sind sie natürlich streng.
Streng vorwürfen aus pures tan ausgesetzt andererseits sie werden sie erhalten sich ihre einflussmöglichkeiten wenigstens darauf daraufhin zu wirken.
Tja also entweder stress mit kasachstan mit profis.
Ja also das ist wirklich 'ne 'ne katastrophale situation und genau deshalb will man solche situationen auch einfach gar nicht haben.
Kommen wir zum nächsten thema ne.
Machen wir mal.
Das nächste thema ist mit hacking.
Hawking oh.
Ja und zwar gibt es eine sehr schöne sehr schönen bericht sehr sehr.
Aufwendig äh aufbereitete bericht des bayerischen rundfunks ist eine,
gemeinsame recherche mehrere autorinnen und autoren hakan eckart jan stroh maximilian cira und rebecca.
Sie das tut mir sehr leid dass ich den namen spontan,
nicht aussprechen konnte mit c und es und i und,
haben sie in zwei sprachen gemacht finde ich vor allem war sehr interessant so grafisch aufbereitet diese website da hat nochmal jemand sich richtig mühe gegeben.
Design steffen kühne da geht es um einen wahnsinnig auf,
die deutsche industrie der titel lautet auch angriff auf das herz der deutschen industrie und zwar geht's um eine heckegruppe und eine gleichnamigen software.
Mit dem namen vinci die zur anwendung kommt um viele,
unternehmen in der deutschen industrie anzugreifen und auszuspielen also letztendlich ein trojaner eine trojaner software die bei vielen unternehmen in deutschland und auch weltweit,
gefunden wurde und in dem bericht wir werden so die indizien zusammengefügt.
Warum davon ausgegangen wird dass es sich hierbei um eine chinesisch um eine chinesische,
schön interessen folgende gruppe handeln,
könnte interessant finde ich auch in dem bericht steht wieder das haupt einfallstor was zu der infektion führt ist,
bei vielen unternehmen eben fishing also das zusenden von in der regel microsoft office dokumenten mit aktiven inhalten also makro s und ich klage ja schon immer und immer wieder nicht zum ersten mal.
Über diese katastrophe die eigentlich diese office markus für unternehmens it darstellen der,
also markus sind kleine oder auch große skripte mit anderen worten programme die in office dokumente eingefügt werden,
können und dort dinge tun das heißt euer dokument indem ihr irgendwie rum tippt und text schreiben könnt und sachen markieren könnt oder sonst was wird von einem,
naja simuliert ein blatt papier tatsächlich zu einem programm auf eurem computer und dieses programm hat dann eben auch alle,
oder viele handlungsmöglichkeiten die so programme eben auf euren rechnern haben unter anderem diese wunderschöne funktion
sich eine datei aus dem internet herunterzuladen und diese auszuführen was eben wenige zeilen in so einem.
Fische basic makro sind dass man ganz einfach in eine partei einfügen kann leuten per e-mail schickt zwar warnt.
Word oder excess hier ersetzbar office davor dass sich hier ein makro in der datei befindet.
Aber allein dieses user interface ist wirklich ein traum denn es gibt quasi die warnung und dann gibt es einen riesigen knopf.
Wo drauf steht äh so etwas wie aktive inhalte oder inhalte aktivieren und dann rechts am rand zu ganz kleines winzig kleines kraus kreuzchen,
was der weg in die sicherheit wäre ja also schon jeder mensch der einmal vor dieser saß braucht nicht unbedingt,
ein studium der psychologie um zu erkennen dass auch sehr gut vierte schimpansen in der regel eher den großen knopf drücken weil er einfacher zu drinnen ist.
Ihre firma nicht ruinieren ja nein.
Genau also es kommt ja wirklich ihr kennt das zum beispiel auch wenn ihr auf irgendwelche webseiten geht mit einem neuen browser oder so und euch euch nahe gelegt wird doch einmal bitte kurz hier
eure seele zu fair und eine spülmaschine zu kaufen und außerdem noch alle cookies zu akzeptieren und,
und und und und und ja wo immer sagt jetzt steht weiter,
und da drunter so wie klein in so 'n ganz schwach hinterlegten kraut und zart auf schlechten displays kaum zu erkennen schritt größe sechs steht so nein,
ja und genau das ist das interface von microsoft office für hacking ja oder nein platt machen hier den laden ja oder nein was haben wir heute dort es ist gerade auf dem schirm auch letzte woche wieder elf krankenhäuser in deutschland oder was betroffen
die auch alle das also das funktioniert immer so und es funktioniert seit,
so vielen jahren so dass man nicht mehr weiß wie lange das so funktioniert und das ist der haupt.
Das haupt dreizehn krankenhäuser sogar ja,
weil eine ganze träger gesellschaft in in in nordrhein-westfalen oder wo war das,
betroffen war ja also klassik klassiker und nichts dagegen unternommen ja diese ist nach wie vor scheiße es wird nicht einfach sinnvoll darüber erklärt was was man hier gerade tut,
dass man nämlich letztendlich so also es ist eigentlich so ein russisches roulette knopf na so hier es gibt code wird hinaus führen ja so.
Hey ich habe hier eine echse für dich,
klickst du die oder nicht kann sein also wenn du vielleicht ist in ordnung ne vielleicht ist das der neue oder so aber wenn du pech hast eben der neue.
Und warum ich das so aufregt ist erstens weil jetzt eine interface seid so und so viel generation nichts sinnvolles geändert haben und zweitens,
da wo wir solche situationen haben wurde mich irgendwie nicht vertrauenswürdig der code eine rolle spielt da haben wir seit jeher lösungen für wir haben's gerade angesprochen coaching fertig
thema erledigt du kannst mit einem lennox mit einem gängigen gängigen system über eine verbindung eine software runterladen du hast ein paar vertrauens zertifikate in dem,
in den betriebssystem drin
und dann sagt der pass auf das für dich aus oder das das installiere ich das installiere ich nicht modernere also moderne deshalb betriebssysteme make us windows haben alle diese dinge also wir führen nur code aus vertrauenswürdig quellen aus das war alles nicht von heute auf morgen einführt bar ja aber in dieser office makro welt
da sitzen wir zwanzig neunzehn mit so einem,
knopf der der einfach so random ist ne roulette russisches roulette wollen sie also wollen sie russisches roulette spielen oder nicht und wir sind alle darauf trainiert diesen knopf,
möglichst oft und schnell zu drücken um weiter arbeiten zu können und ich ich habe den kaffee auf.
Gott feiert vor microsoft,
ja es ist äh ist ein bisschen ich meine man muss sich das so ein bisschen so vorstellen wieso man kriegt auf der party von unbekannten ein getränk gereicht ja wir trinken mal.
Ja nur dass das in der regel gut geht ja im vergleich zu microsoft office eine datei.
Ich würde lieber auf 'ner party wie ein getränk anbieten lassen.
Also lieber karo tropfen als.
Also die wahrscheinlichkeit für kavo tropfen auf 'ner party ist glaube ich geringer,
als irgendwie wenn ich mir jetzt einfach nur die nachrichten der letzten woche anschaue weil beides probleme sind und beides tut man nicht ne man trinkt keine getränke aus unbekannten quellen,
und es ist auch kein essen aus und vertrauenswürdig fällen und man installiert keine software aus nicht vertrauenswürdig quellen deswegen hat microsoft office natürlich eigentlich auf computer nichts verloren weil aus einer vertrauenswürdig fälle kommt dass er nicht.
Ich habe ich weiß nicht wer das letzte mal wird auf meinem computer hatte das war.
Ich hab's ich benutze das seit seit jahren.
Ich glaube ich das letzte mal.
Ich bin ich bin zahlen der kunde bei ja ja ich muss das beruflich benutzen,
komm her nicht dran vorbei ich kann ja nicht jeden kunden den ich habe erst missionieren und sagen nein wir machen das jetzt mit mit mark down und das ist das ist das ist übrigens auch das problem was mit diesen,
markus existiert es wird in großen unternehmen sehr regel benutzt aber meine antwort darauf wäre na dann macht er doch folgendes,
dann macht euch ein schönes zertifikat dann gibt da jeder mitarbeiterin ihr eigenes zertifikat dann können sie ihre markus die sie da schreiben signieren und dann kann ich wenigstens in dem dialog sehen hier gibt's ein marco das marco wurde signiert von was weiß ich
in company was kann da schon schief gehen die haben schon die bundeswehr erfolgreich selig also ihr.
Irgendwie sowas ne aber nichts es gibt nichts,
seit jahrzehnten ist das stillstand ich kann mir das ich kann mir das überhaupt nicht mehr erklären weil wenn man es wirklich in allen in allen bereichen der it-sicherheit gibt es eigentlich eine relativ zügige evolution,
nur dass sich die leute per öffnen von nicht vertrauens für den anhänger am laufenden band ihre ihre konzerne zu erschießen das hat noch keiner für wichtig gefunden und die lösung sind eins zu eins übertragbar natürlich kannst du,
coaching für diese für diese scheiß markus machen ist gar kein problem.
Aber findet nicht statt zwanzig neunzehn und wir werden auch weiterhin von berichten müssen weil das geht so schnell nicht weg.
Jetzt will ich noch ganz kurz auf den bericht zurückkommen.
Denn was sie da auch gemacht haben warum ich denn überhaupt erwähne ist sie haben dann ein detektor genutzt,
ein emma plugin was irgendwie schon zwanzig sechzehn uhr so von mitarbeitern von thyssenkrupp geschrieben wurde und haben damit halt mal durch das internet so durch gescannt und ja mehrere betroffene unternehmen,
und auch institutionen gefunden unter anderem die regierung von hongkong und haben dann bescheid gesagt übrigens hier die auf der büchse läuft dieser wind hier auf der wirkstoff dieser vinci und haben den bescheid gesagt und was ich sehr interessant finde.
Oder erwähnenswert finde in diesem bericht ist das.
Sich hier meine häufig vertretene und immer wieder wiederholte these wieder replay ziert das auch sogenannte advanced präsident also,
bezahlte angreifer gruppen mit einem konkreten ziel auch immer nur
so hoch springen wie es die hürde verlangt die nutzen zur infektion irgendwelche e-mail anhänge und ihre schadsoftware ist da teilweise auch seit seit langer zeit nicht weiterentwickelt worden also wenn irgendwie
vor mehreren jahren ein direktion skript für deine schadsoftware geschrieben wurde,
mit mit dessen hilfe eben infizierte maschinen gefunden werden können und du,
neunzehn teile dieser software immer noch im einsatz hast dann zeigt das eben dass du eigentlich kein besonderen evolution druck unterwegs.
Du musst ja du kannst ja einfach du wirst ja nicht die neue ebene software einsetzen wenn du mit der alten noch durchkommt denn du würdest ja nur mehr über deine fähigkeiten und
und techniken und möglichkeiten verraten wenn du das tust insofern gibt es auch ja eine,
einen kritischen blick auf diese publikation von denjenigen die ihren lebensunterhalt damit verdienen,
solche hacker gruppen zu monitoren zu jagen zu erkennen und aus ihren system aus den systemen,
ihres eigenes unternehmens oder ihrer kunden herauszuhalten weil sie dann sagen naja durch so eine veröffentlichung die wird dann
international wahrgenommen dann werden suchen alle nach den den indikator auf kompromiss kegeln die leute wieder raus schaffen's nicht wirklich
und letztendlich haben wir effiziente erkennung möglichkeiten verloren und sind können quasi haben quasi.
Intelligence über unsere gegner verbrannt,
ist ein also beide argumente sind so halb tragbar ne ich mein natürlich ist es wichtig solche angreifer aus den systemen rauszuhalten.
Und dieses wissen sollte zumindest innerhalb der community immer offen geteilt werden es gibt natürlich einige marktteilnehmer die versuchen das in irgendeiner form zu,
zu eigentum zu machen und ins körbchen modelle oder sowas zu überführen aber letztendlich ist es natürlich gut über solche angriffe bescheid zu wissen und wenn wir möglichst viel darüber wissen aber wichtiger wäre vor allem,
endlich mal die verantwortlichen software hersteller tragbar e effiziente gegenmaßnahmen entwickeln und
das ist eben kein rocket science das ist uns seit vielen vielen jahren bekannt,
wie wir vertrauens fähigkeit sicherstellen das ist eine erfindung die ist jetzt irgendwie gefühlt zwanzig jahre alt und warum setzt man die in den hoch kritischen bereichen nicht um.
Wie bono machen sie mal hier eine neue verschwörungstheorie auf.
Ich hatte am ende profitiere ich davon wenn ihr euch nachher nach und nach alle eure unternehmen zerlegt weil weil ihr keine software bekommt,
und weil weil wir uns heute weil heute noch den leuten erklärt wird it-sicherheit muss man sich noch obendrauf kaufen warum eigentlich überhaupt.
Ich weiß nicht vielleicht ist ja irgendwie die ganze große shaker industrie mittlerweile holt ihr uns auf max soft.
Ja ja.
Übrigens also da da habe ich irgendwie vor kurzem einen vortrag darüber gehalten und.
Dann würde ich auch interview.
Nein über über schwachstellen und also menschliches vorstellen und zwar an der universität bochum eine große ehre ja eine einer der führenden universitäten im bereich der it-sicherheit,
viele gute leute kommen dort her.
Und da habe ich einen kleinen vortrag gehalten und danach gab's auch ein ein interview das dann noch auf der seite der universität bochum veröffentlicht wurde das kann ja nur mal hier verlinken,
da habe ich auch schon gewartet also dieses thema ich reg mich da schon länger drüber auf.
Ja das merkt man sofort kommen wir zum anderen aufreger,
ich habe ja heute heute abend schon wieder zwei stunden damit verbracht sim-karte in in geräte reinzustecken irgendwie zuhause wieder internet zu bekommen weil die telekom irgendwie mein derselbe abgedreht hat,
aus noch unklar in gründen und da hat man.
Bezahlt oder was.
Was ist los gleich bezahlt.
Loggen gelogen.
Ja und äh ja nee war einfach ob das vielleicht.
Also jetzt ist aber ganz zügiges netz hier muss ich sagen ich bin ganz ich bin ganz angetan.
Es ist ja auch im studio ich sprach von meinem heim.
Und im heim sah es nicht so gut aus daten heim und na ja wie auch immer auf jeden fall habe ich wieder mal diesen ganzen wahnsinn mit sind karten anfassen dürfen.
Nano sind karten wie groß im karten.
Achso du wolltest es irgendwie eine nanu sind wir in der fritz box schieben mit vier adapter toren und.
Was kann ich jetzt wo reinstecken und wie rum und aber,
es gibt noch ein anderes problem mit sim karten und das ist auch vielfältig weil was sich leute nicht so richtig klar machen ist welche bedeutung sind karten heutzutage haben sind karten auch selber,
an sicher auch nochmal eine ganze menge probleme da kann ich auch nochmal auf meinen,
security verweisen sodass auch mal schön aufgedrückt wird gut da drin läuft und so denn das sind ja auch nur kleine computer,
gesehen sind die sim-karte und vor allem mittlerweile einfach die identifizierung im netz da mobilfunk rufnummern.
Mittlerweile so ein bisschen der zweite ausweis geworden sind also mobilfunknetze werden heute für allerlei impliziert der identifizierung verwendet und auch explizite man kennt das man will bei der bank was überweisen dann gibt's eine tan,
per sms oder man macht generell zwei faktor authentizität bei irgendwelchen web diensten darüber was immer noch besser ist als wenn man gar keine zwei faktoren identifizierung hat aber man verlagert im prinzip diesen zusätzlichen sicherheitspersonal
ein system wo es eben mit der sicherheit auch nicht so weit her ist das hat viele gründe vor allem hat es,
diese ganze mobilfunk welt eben aus der telekom industrie herauskommt und eben nicht aus dieser internet industrie und da ist ja schon so einiges im eimer aber der telekom,
seite ist es also setzt sich die deutsche telekom sondern generell alte kommunikations- unternehmen und diese ganzen standards body der dranhängt gemeint,
da ist es eben auch schwierig da sicherheitsstandards durchzusetzen erinnert sich jetzt gerade so ein bisschen aber es noch 'ne menge zu holen,
weil eben diese sim-karte letzten endes dem telefon und damit dann auch dem provider mit dem ich mich dann verbinde sagt welche mobilfunk nummer ich habe sind sie halt relativ.
Richtig.
Minimale kultur sagt nicht wirklich welche nummer du hast gesagt welche welche identität du hast ja.
Na ja aber sie authentizität mich gegenüber dem dem im netz und diese sim-karte ist dem netzbekannt und da gibt es dann eben die zuordnung zu meinem account.
Darf ich ja ganz kurz noch zu sagen.
Subscriber identity modul und äh ist also die der name also dafür steht sim und deshalb sie dient der sicheren aufbewahrung des schlüssel materials,
für die drei oder vier authentizität und nachher auch verschlüsselung des funk verkehrs und der grund warum die auf diesen karten ist ist damit sie nicht
klonen bar sind
weil also das hatte gar nicht unbedingt damit zu tun dass wir als subscriber geschützt werden sollen sondern vielmehr dass die sorge bestand was machen wir denn wenn der tim sich eine telekom flatrate holt,
für für was weiß ich was kostet was.
Achtzig euro.
Ja die anfänger tarife dann einmal 'ne richtige.
Der richtige gibts jetzt für achtzig euro.
Achtzig nur ja okay aber ach so.
Aber jede weitere aber jede.
Kostet.
Jede weitere sind kostet fünfundzwanzig euro und der tim hat jetzt einen kleinen kopierer und sagt ich geb mal noch eine sinn an den linus und noch eine sind hier und hier und hier und hier und dann wäre ja quasi eine,
dieser sim-karte möglich das würde,
in dem moment wurde sie kopierst aber auch dem mobilfunknetz wehtun wenn sich die gleiche sind zwei mal ein buch dann wird es damit wird das netz nicht ohne weiteres klarkommen es wird dann eine von beiden einfach immer rauswerfen.
Weshalb du eben eine multi bräuchtest und deswegen ist auf deiner sinn in deine identität und nicht wirklich deine telefonnummer kannst du auch deine telefonnummer wechseln mit der gleichen sim-karte weiter verwenden.
Genau und die sim-karte können natürlich auch vom netz unterschied unterschieden werden die haben also alle eine andere i die letzten endes aber auf denselben account und damit eben auf meine telefonnummer zeigen.
Wenn so etwas so wichtig ist in einem solchen sicherheitsproblem dass dann weg das natürlich begehrlichkeiten denn man kann sich ja ganz gut vorstellen in dem moment wo man kontrolle über diese telefonnummer bekommen kann kann man dadurch natürlich zum beispiel auch,
die selben prozesse nachspielen das heißt wenn man sich irgendwo einloggt und es kommt um zwei faktor identifizierung dazu,
und man hat kontrolle über diesen kanal könnte man das abfangen wenn man eine banküberweisung machen will und da kommt die tanne darüber dann heißt zugriff auf das telefon eben auch zugriff auf diese transaktionen s nummer,
und da dachte sich in österreich die staatsanwaltschaft auch so ist das.
Wer macht denn wer kann denn diese identitäten herstellen wenn's die user nicht selber können na ja der mobilfunk betreiber und da hatten sie,
falls ich weiß es nicht genau in dem bericht
wurde nicht erwähnt um welche mobilfunk betreiber sich hatte lediglich um ein der in österreich aktiv ist und noch nicht gesagt worum es ging in diesem fall aber es wurde sozusagen jemand,
gegen jemand ermittelt und sollten da irgendwelche überwachungs maßnahmen vollzogen werden und sie werden wohl auch ganz gerne auf accounts zugreifen und haben jetzt
quasi diesen mobilfunk provider der für diese telefonnummer dieses users zuständig war angeschrieben und einfach gesagt,
hier überwachungs maßnahme gib mal sinn.
Mach uns mal eine weitere simpel quasi so eine multi sind die nicht vom kunden bestellt wurde die auf demselben account geht und am besten konfiguriert das mal bei euch auch noch so dass die sms dann auf diese sim-karte geht und nicht auf die andere die
ursprünglich wurde nämlich schon zerstört von dem user selber
dann haben wir ja dann prima tool mit dem wir da irgendwie zugriff.
Ich weiß dass das mobilfunknetz gesagt hat fünfundzwanzig euro.
Pro monat.
Aber immerhin der mobilfunk provider hat sich gewehrt und hat dagegen klage erhoben,
was in dem moment leider keine aufschieben die wirkung hatte das heißt sie mussten zunächst einmal der aufforderung der staatsanwaltschaft qual ihrer power,
dienst leisten,
folge leisten sprich sie werden da eine sim-karte erzeugt haben haben wir dagegen geklagt und das oberland oder landesgericht jetzt weiß ich nicht wie das in österreich so gehandhabt wird da heißt ja mal alles ein bisschen anders also das lg
wien hat nun dieser klage stattgegeben weil wie sie feststellte ist für diese forderung der staatsanwaltschaft keine rechtliche grundlage gab nein.
Unglaublich unglaublich was was die alles nicht rausnehmen was erlaube.
Zum kann nehmen sie sind karten raus.
Es ist.
Was jetzt mit die die österreicher.
Na überhaupt hier kasachstan österreich.
All diese ganzen ende mittel.
Staatsanwalt staatsanwaltschaft in der mittel ja zeigt aber andererseits auch dass natürlich dieser
trennt der mittlerweile auch schon wieder rückläufig ist muss man sagen der trend handy nummern zur identifizierung zu benutzen nicht so gut ist und wer da irgendwie über andere maßnahmen
nachdenken.
Da habe ich schon zwanzig dreizehn äh von abgeraten aber es ist letztendlich als ich meine.
Ist schon zwanzig zwölf.
Ich habe es schriftlich gemacht in der demenz stellungnahme damals aber die,
also es gibt was die sim-karte gibt 's natürlich zwei perspektiven die eine ist dass es die die smart karte die alle menschen haben.
Oder fast alle menschen ne also die ähm so dass es immer wieder überlegungen gab zu sagen okay können wir auf der sim-karte können wir nicht geilere sim-karte den leuten in ihre geräte geben dass man da noch ein
personalausweis oder dass man halt eine story lösungen hat oder so ne und,
insofern schlagen da auch quasi zwei herzen meiner wurst weil.
Über längere zeit war eigentlich immer das mobilfunknetz der schwächere der schwächere problem als die sim-karte diesen karten waren eigentlich immer sicher es gab nur.
Wann haben wir das präsentiert zwanzig fünfzehn oder so sind karten heck und dann gab's diesen kommen.
Die zwei klonen hat mir neunzigern.
Genau das waren das war danach fahren sie dann erst mal sicher dann gab 's nochmal schwachstellen zwanzig fünfzehn aber eigentlich sind diese sim-karte so halbwegs.
Zwanzig fünfzehn nein das war auf der oben zwanzig dreizehn.
Also es ist zumindest diese diese eine.
Es ist viel drauf rumgehackt worden ist nicht so viel bei rausgekommen ist schon.
Im vergleich zu was du aus einem mobilfunknetz rausholt ist eine sim-karte schon eigentlich ein relativ.
Gut angehangen aber in dem moment wo wo es das aber ja letztendlich nicht die sim-karte selber ist die security herstellt sondern letztlich nur diese zuordnung zu dem account beim provider da ist natürlich jetzt dieser weg
sehr naheliegend wenn auch frech ja die man einfach sagt na ja dann mach doch einfach nochmal eine sim-karte dazu erzählt keinem raute telefonanrufe und
sms entsprechend um und fertig ist die lucy und
üblich dass sich dieser propeller da jetzt auch dagegen gestellt hat das ist ja auch nicht unbedingt selbstverständlich und weiß der geier wie oft sowas schon an anderen stellen gelaufen ist also man kann jetzt mal an andere länder denken wo es um rechtsstaat ist nicht ganz so weit ist da kann man mal davon ausgehen dass das sozusagen
gang und gäbe es weil auf die idee sind sie bestimmt auch schon bekommen und von daher sollte man eben davon abgesehen sprich wenn ihr,
factor irgendwo aufsetzt und ihr habt die wahl.
Dann ist vielleicht die sms nicht so geile idee da gibt's dann irgendwie einfach so zwei faktoren die kirche so so passwort generatoren zum beispiel eine kleine app die man sich installiert
da wird man dann einmal so ein installieren drauf dann läuft das auf dem eigenen telefon und man kann sich quasi dann immer nur
also alle dreißig sekunden neue nummer anzeigen lassen die man dann ein gibt dass es ganz praktisch da wo man es machen kann ist das schon mal besser weil da hat dann sozusagen kein.
Die mobilfunk nummer erstmal keine bilder keine rolle.
Also die sind,
das ist in der tat eine ganz schöne lösung und die auch für dieses angriffs modell sehr angemessen ist ja wenn du also deine sim-karte wird halt nicht so einfach geklaut aber.
Es du hast halt dann das problem dass diese.
Was du da jetzt in dieser app speichert wird natürlich nicht auf einem auf einer sim-karte gespeichert und das bedeutet es wird einfach auf ein normaler.
Stories gespeichert wenn du jetzt irgendwie ein älteres telefon hast und nicht in einem secure stories in denen du nur unter gewissen bedingungen dran kommst ne also
die offenthal cata apps speichern sich diese initiative dinge halt irgendwie auf ihrer auf ihrer,
auf der auf dem flash speicher am telefon und dann hast du halt das die herausforderung dass du wieder solchen celebrity angriffen ausgesetzt bist das heißt hätte unser junger mann hier,
ich gehe davon aus dass ein mann ist sowas genutzt dann hätten sie im zweifelsfall sein telefon einfach mit einem mit der klassischen hacking software aufgemacht und hätten dann,
die die app in ihren händen gehabt ne also es.
Ja gut aber das telefon.
Frage des modells.
Hatten sie wohl in dem fall schon aber da muss,
die sicherheit des geräts aber hier war ja sozusagen die geräte sicherheit vollkommen irrelevant weil du einfach,
ja einfach schon einen schritt davor weit weg irgendwo in einer anderen stadt.
Das oben links also nichts ist perfekt aber konkret dieses problem dass der mobilfunk ich meine es gibt ja noch andere dramen
die dir die den zugriff auf deine daten dann sozusagen auch erschweren was ist wenn ihr quasi einfach gekündigt wird ja der die sachen einfach ja nee hier keine ahnung aber ich habe
bezahlt ja und so egal wie man es in account einfach zu weil wir sind total verstört
dann stehst du da und hast diesen kanal verloren also man muss sich natürlich immer um backups gedanken machen und wenn ich so ein,
zwei fa zugang einrichten das was ich hier so geht habe oder so ja so wichtige accounts wo man wirklich sicherstellen möchte
dass die nicht flöten gehen weil da ein großes problem
nicht dann richtet man das ein und dann tue ich das aber nicht nur auf mein telefon sondern kriegt man auch noch so einen dazu und der kommt da nochmal irgendwie ausgedruckt in irgendeinen anderen selbst also.
Jeder ist da unterschiedlich paranoid aber muss halt immer davon ausgehen irgendwann verliert immer eure scheiße und ihr solltet euch langsam mal angewöhnen irgendwo ein ort zu haben in eurem
heim und im idealfall vielleicht auch noch irgendjemand anderes heim wo dann entsprechend wiederum gesichert diese informationen hinterlegt werden also was was ich verschlüsselte usb-stick festplatte was auch immer
dass ihr eben im zweifelsfall wenn euch was böses widerfährt muss jetzt nicht immer gleich,
ein einbruch sein aber was ich die hütte brennt ab oder andere geschichten dann hast du einfach das.
Es ist schon eigentlich interessantes dass wir uns irgendwie dazu entscheiden ausgerichtet dass eine,
gerät was wir haben was letztendlich den höchsten wert hat die höchste begehrlichkeiten und am einfachsten zu klauen ist,
das wollte unbedingt als authentizität sektor nehmen das ist auch so eine sache muss ich überlegen im zweifelsfall wird 's euch nicht gezockt weil weil da irgendwie kein material drauf ist für die zwei faktoren zertifizierung
aber wenn euch irgendwas geklaut wird dann im zweifelsfall euer handy.
Aber wenn das handy weg ist es ist ich mein selbst wenn das was gibt man heute für ein handy aus vierzig tausend euro
ne das gibt mir leute aus für ein handy keine ahnung tausende oder sowas ne oder oder vierhundert euro oder zweihundert euro also was kann welches ich will jetzt nicht quasi die untergrenze des handys feststellen dass man noch mit gutem gewissen benutzen könnte.
Leute geben von vierzig bis vierzigtausend euro.
Vierzigtausend euro handy wenn ihr ein handy haben wollt für vierzigtausend euro ich hab eins.
Meter ebene.
Genau also alles peanuts im vergleich zu fünf,
milliarden dollar äh die facebook nämlich als strafe bezahlen musste wir haben das erwähnt schon in der sendung deswegen
wie das jetzt eher kurz behandelt wir haben gesagt wir hatten erwähnt dass das wohl die höhe der strafe ist die facebook für seinen cambridge analytica skandal
von der fc,
aufgedrückt bekommt aber jetzt stellt sich die gesamte teil dieser einigung raus also quasi eine außergerichtliche einigung in der.
Die fc außerdem ein paar aufschlagen durchgesetzt hat zum beispiel muss der facebook verwaltungsrat jetzt eine neue abteilung nur für die datenschutz aus.
Einrichten und die sollen dann mark zuckerberg irgendwie auf die finger gucken und seine macht ein,
dem und die behörde kann zuckerberg in zukunft persönlich dafür verantwortlich machen wenn gegen datenschutz regeln verstoßen wird im gegenzug.
Machen sie aber jetzt eigentlich,
niemanden verantwortlich und sagen nur mit dieser zahlung dieser fünf milliarden us-dollar,
ist das problem geklärt facebook hatte aber schon im ersten quartal zwanzig neunzehn drei milliarden auf seite gelegt.
Mach mal ja mal ich mach das jetzt nicht jedes quartal aber man also ist auch ein bisschen 'ne frage der nachhaltigkeit ne und,
allein in dem film jahr hat facebook immer noch zwei komma vier drei milliarden us-dollar gewinn gemacht und,
facebook hat ohnehin damit gerechnet dass die strafe auf fünf milliarden hinauslaufen könnte so viel,
zu dieser angelegenheit und jetzt stellt sich aber raus in der fc gab es keine einstimmige.
Also keine einstimmige abstimmung soweit ich das erinnere aus der letzten sendung glaube ich drei zu zwei stimmen und jetzt hat der hit shop
ein design thinking world veröffentlicht das erinnern vielleicht einige von euch noch als wir mit der constanze über die kommission,
gesprochen haben vor einigen jahren wo also quasi gesagt wurde okay es gibt den bericht und dann gibt es halt das minderheiten votum.
Von denen die die überstimmt wurde aber trotzdem nochmal sagen hier das ist für die minderheit aber das muss gesagt werden und da hat der das ist also jetzt auf der fc seite auch veröffentlicht von dem comission,
zwanzig seiten in denen er folgende kern argumente vorträgt erstens.
Dieser ganze cambridge analytica skandal ist ein direktes ergebnis.
Des advertising models was das geschäftsmodell von facebook ist wir haben facebook nur gebaut um.
Quasi das verhalten von menschen zum monitoren und ihn darauf an auf ihrem verhalten und ihren persönlichkeit vielen angemessene,
zu präsentieren das hat er richtig erkannt und das ist das wir haben glaube ich damals auch schon gesagt
was da eigentlich bei cambridge analytica passiert ist ist dass sich jemand die leistungen von facebook die funktionen von facebook erschlichen hat ohne dafür zu bezahlen wenn sie bezahlt hätten wir alles okay gewesen.
Ja
zweitens sagt er dieses segment also diese einigung zwischen fc und facebook bezahl mal fünf milliarden dann ist gut.
Macht wenig,
irgendwas am business modell von facebook oder den praktiken die facebook täglich ausübt zu ändern auch das ist richtig.
Des weiteren wird facebook vom haken gelassen für,
weitere nicht näher spezifisch vierte verletzungen und bekommt quasi eine pauschale immunität jetzt geschenkt na das ist ja der teil dieser.
Solche einigung funktionieren ja so dass man sagt okay zahlt jetzt diesen preis und er spart ihr den restlichen ärger ne das wird wird irgendwie
das ist dann so ein kräftemessen wo wo eigentlich gesagt fit naja wir
haben vielleicht nicht alles gegen dich in der hand und wir wollen uns die arbeit sparen wir stellen das verfahren jetzt ein gegen eine zahlung von so und so mit dieser zahlung wird aber natürlich auch nicht,
die schuld anerkannt das hat facebook ja in diesem fall genau nicht getan und das ist wahrscheinlich auch das was sie sich hier gerade fünf milliarden euro an kosten lassen dass ihr aus der nummer rauskommen ohne.
Noch irgendwo und quasi wissen jetzt gibt's ein cat und alles was davor noch war es jetzt quasi mit abgegolten zweitens wir haben dafür eben auch eine pauschale immunität und drittens wir muss unsere schuldig anerkennen was eben,
im us rechtssystem aber auch im deutschen rechtssystem immer gerne mal auch eine rolle spielt fünf milliarden sind zu wenig sagt er,
also gemessen an der kohle die facebook umsetzt und auch ein sehr wichtiger satz also kann da auch bei amerika die hoffnung nicht aufgeben also hier geht es gar nicht um privatsphäre,
hier geht es über die macht zu kontrollieren und zu manipulieren und deswegen sagt er in seinem,
das wort also seinem nicht übereinstimmen votum dass das alles was jetzt passiert ist quasi am thema vorbeigeht und ich finde er hat da relativ gute punkte angebracht deswegen,
wollte ich das hier noch mit in die facebook analen.
So dann haben wir noch diesen ganzen rum.
Wo die amerikaner die welt verrückt machen weil ja so gefährlich sind und alle müssen jetzt mitspielen weil amerika first und wenn wir was wollen,
dann haben wir alle ordentlich zu springen und sie versuchen halt alle möglichen länder dazu zu bekommen hier mit zu springen.
Insbesondere natürlich ihre freunde von den fünf augen.
Wir erinnern uns das ist dieser spionage verbunden nicht nur die usa angehören sondern eben auch kanada australien neuseeland und,
das vereinigte königreich von großbritannien und nordirland zu zergehen lassen schön dass noch klingt ja nicht mehr lange so sein.
Und während so aus reihen und neuseeland da auch schnell,
da sie ja nicht viel power haben gegen zu halten schnell irgendwie den bei gesprungen sind auch gesagt haben ja war war ich total böse machen wir mit,
sind wohl kanada und auch großbritannien da nicht ganz und freunde.
Wir haben gesagt weiß ich gar nicht ob das so sinnvoll ist.
Ich muss noch ganz kurz zu diesem thema sanktionen.
Was sagen das ist ja immer so was das hört man irgendwie so im in den nachrichten jetzt gibt's sanktionen und du darfst kein wow benutzen und du musst jetzt den iran sanktionieren und so ne das ist tatsächlich ziemlich krass,
wenn so etwas wirklich passiert also wow hey ist da noch 'n relativ einfacher fall wir kommen nachher noch.
Zum thema eines gesamten landes wo eben gesagt wird okay hier sanktionen gegen was weiß ich iran sanktionen gegen nordkorea dann darf,
in genannten geschäftsbereichen oder in allen geschäftsbereichen einfach niemand,
in dieser links in diesem legislativen bereich mehr geschäfte mit diesem land machen da stehen aber teilweise seit jahrzehnten geschäftsbeziehung das geht so weit wie das.
Quasi bestimmte fabriken keine zulieferung mehr aus dem land erhalten dürfen weil sie dem land kein geld mehr geben dürfen und dann zumachen müssen das geht in irgendwelche versicherungsverträge ein wo irgendwie großes internationales
geld irgendwie drin liegt was was ich eine gebäudeversicherung im.
Ja wir hatten das ja auch deutlich schon.
Sicherung aus aus den usa oder so.
Neulich schon ne google app store darf dann auf einmal nicht mehr irgendwelche updates ausliefern weil diese ganzen verträge erliegen arm kann auf einmal keine professoren mehr liefern also das hat alles erhebliche.
Jedenfalls wären wehrt sich das national cybersecurity center c gegen diese forderung,
der usa,
und sagt das risiko diese komponenten in fünf g netzen zu betreiben stufen wir als durchaus beherrscht bar ein ich würde sagen ihre argumente dafür sind wir haben das auch in den zwei drei vier letzten drin,
so und wir erinnern uns aber auch dass großbritannien damals nämlich gesagt hat als es um diese diesen balkon king dass sie sagten so ja also,
ende in unser korn kommen die nicht rein in unser unter keinen umständen niemals so und,
wir haben natürlich damit verschwiegen dass der größere teil der kosten für den bau eines mobilfunknetze insbesondere wenn fünf g netz bauspar die zellen immer noch ein paar hundert meter weit reichen ist natürlich
der aufbau von zellen,
und quasi eine die peripherie infrastruktur und das kaufen sich die leute alle bei gerne bei waldi ein weil sie effektiv.
Die dem bestes beste preis-leistungsverhältnis haben und sogar in einigen bereichen besonders in besonderen innovationen vorsprung haben.
Ein mensch aus der branche sagte mir damals linus im moment ist einfach nur der wettkampf der
wie viel sanktionen gegen sie verabschieden können und laut ankündigen können ohne irgendwas an der bisherigen praxis zu ändern und in großbritannien weil nirgendwo wow im chor und deswegen haben sie hat gesagt komm
lass den orangen spinner mal dadurch befrieden dass wir jetzt möglichst laut sagen so vorbei kommt in unseren chor,
ne das wäre so als würdest du jetzt irgendwie sagen so also hier in einem meter ebene kommt kein dell ne,
unter keinen umständen kommt hier denn rein.
Ich bin noch weitergehen einfach kein apple mehr im kühlschrank.
Bei dir zuhause kein apple mehr.
Kein.
Kein kommt kein apple mehr ans kabel netz.
Und genau so das heißt aber da schreibt unser geliebter erich möchel dann eben darüber das wird also jetzt.
Natürlich betrachtet er mit freude das ist jetzt ein zwist in der pfeife eis spionage allianz gibt über diese frage der ja eigentlich von den usa behaupten nationalen sicherheit und,
das wird kann man da genüsslich beobachten denn die das c argumentiert wenn wir nur von drei möglichen lieferanten ein
sofort ausschließen dann haben wir natürlich auch mehr abhängigkeit von den zwei verbleibenden ne und das erhöht die preise das erhöht natürlich auch die die,
den die anfälligkeit des wender mixes und so weiter also da werden wir sehen wie die sich weiter zoffen.
Das ist auch ein interessantes beispiel wie man 's halt auch,
in anführungsstrichen richtig machen kann weil sie halt nicht nur jetzt bei wave einfach produkte kaufen und die kommen dann in der amazon box und dann wird es in zweck geschraubt und fertig
nein ihr habt da ganz weit gehende abkommen das war wir sogar den code präsentieren muss und da haben die sich dann auch mal schön durchgelesen alles sondern erstmal die ganzen die voll passwörter irgendwie aus dem brot raus fresst und einfach sozusagen den ganzen kram auf
klassische programmierer fehler hin und sicherheitslücken untersucht und das nehme ich mal an
auch wieder reporter und so weiter also in beide seitigen interesse sind solche maßnahmen und so kann man eben kooperativ
eben auch wirklich aktiv für sicherheit sorgen anstatt jetzt einfach nur zu sagen da ist jetzt der falsche name auf plastik box außen dran machen wir nicht und jetzt war total sicher war das irgendwie keller.
Wir bleiben noch mal kurz bei den sanktionen denn auch eine meldung der
der heutigen woche also auch eine meldung laut gelacht habe denn wird vorgeworfen möglicherweise us sanktionen gegen nordkorea unterlaufen zu haben
ja wer sollte denn sonst
wahrscheinlich hält sich aus china an an us sanktionen gegen nordkorea.
Natürlich und zwar geht es darum ganz schlimm,
also kurz hintergrund also es gibt verschiedene sanktionen der united nations und der eu.
Wegen gegen nordkorea wegen menschenrechtsverletzungen und des dort betriebenen kern waffen programms und,
aus diesem grunde gibt es für viele bereiche waffen luxusgüter seltene erden irgendwelche export restriktionen.
Nach nordkorea und china,
hat diese resolution in der vergangenheit immer mal ganz gerne als vorschlag interpretiert,
warum macht china das naja also nordkorea ist relativ nah an china dran,
china äh nennt sich offiziell glaube ich noch kommunismus nordkorea wahrscheinlich auch.
Ja genau volksrepublik lupen reine demokratien effektiv aber china,
kein interesse daran dass in nordkorea einen regimewechsel stattfindet der letztendlich dann den einfluss der usa in der region erhöhen würde und letztendlich auch zu einer militärischen bedrohung werden könnte
kann sich natürlich vorstellen aus der,
aus der bekannten politik der usa dass sie schon wert darauf legen relativ nah an ihren potenziellen gegnern.
Sehr freundliche abhängigen verbündete zu haben und dort mal die ein oder andere rakete zu parken einfach nur um für ein kräfte gleichgewicht,
zu sorgen zwischen der rechten hand der usa und der linken hand der usa.
Und deswegen ist natürlich klar dass china als letztes sagen würde wir bauen jetzt nordkorea kein drei netz.
Drei kinder nordkorea wer soll das denn sonst bauen also die haben wir alle sanktionen also es kann ja nur china bauen
insofern naja also die die die dokumente des bezeugen soll wurden geliebt von einem mitarbeiter von geht um arbeitsverträge,
verträge kalkulationen tabellen und angeblich gibt es da eine datenbank mit der sie die welt ihre weltweiten aktivitäten,
koordinieren und in denen seien länder wie iran syrien nordkorea mit codes verschlüsselt worden und der code von nordkorea war an neun.
Und dann hatten sie ein so 'n strom an unternehmen panda international information technology die dann irgendwie.
Offenbar nordkorea dabei unterstützt haben sich im internet zu bauen und,
hat dann eine stellungnahme veröffentlichen der sie sagen sie halten sich uneingeschränkt an die geltende gesetze und vorschriften in den ländern in denen sie tätig sind.
Also wir konnten nichts feststellen was gegen den nordkoreanische gesetze wird stoßen hätte.
Und sie sagen aber nochmal sie schließen die export kontrolle und sanktionen gesetze sowie vorschriften der united nation usa und e u ein und dieses unternehmen panda was da offenbar eben der.
Die arbeit erledigt hat statt jetzt für eine stellungnahme nicht zur verfügung ich finde das also ganz ehrlich ich meine netzwerke bauen sorry das habe ich irgendwie noch nie für schlechte behalten gefunden und wer also,
ich sehe wenig anlass in nordkorea den bau von von internet infrastrukturen zu unterbinden.
Auch wenn nordkorea auf jeden fall seine echos hat wird sicherlich kein schlechteres nordkorea weil die leute haben.
Wahrscheinlich habe sowieso nur die führung skala telefon von daher ist es irgendwie.
Okay dass das stimmt ähm das mag sein aber ja also irgendjemand muss die sanktionen brechen china.
Hat's gemacht skandal.
Wissen wir machen wir das.
Genau das ist der eigentliche skandal ja warum hat hier warum haben wir denn nicht schöne was weiß ich siemens technologien geliefert letztendlich einfach zu ruinieren.
Und eine schöne demokratie hin zu bauen das wäre dass wir das wäre cool gewesen zu sagen komm wir schicken euch ein paar leute von uns
terrorisieren das gesamte land und dann dann baut ihr da einfach selber was eigenes schönes wieder auf und lasst euch das nicht von den amerikanern irgendwie diktieren raketen parkplatz oder sowas.
Hacking von geheimdiensten hat tradition in in,
usa und in deutschland weniger aber ein dienstleister,
der russischen behörden unter anderem des vfb wurde gehackt soviel wie,
siebeneinhalb terabyte an da hatten sollen daraus getragen worden sein.
Keiner weiß wo die hin sind angeblich wurden teile davon im netz veröffentlicht und geben nun allerlei aufschluss über bestrebungen
der russischen behörden und des russischen geheimdienste es mal schauen wie sich das noch weiterentwickelt und damit.
Sind wir glaube ich durch mit den kurz meldungen und können noch ein termin ankündigen.
Ja das ist nur einer kleiner feiner und ausnahmsweise auch mal wieder in eigener sache denn die nächste konferenz mit dem,
trick reichen namen das ist nichts politik auszeichnen datum.
Ja das versuche ich gerade panisch zu finden.
Panisch.
Wir haben es in der letzten sendung glaube ich angekündigt nein vorletzte schön ich scrolle mal hier durch.
Aber auf jeden fall.
Vornherein machen dreizehnter september.
Ihr wisst bescheid ihr wisst bescheid.
September das ist ein freitag das quasi der auftakt wieder in so ein wildes berlin wochenende was er natürlich gerne mitnehmen,
und für die ganze stadt in der volksbühne aber wir wollen gar nicht so sehr über diese veranstaltung reden weil das haben wir ja schon getan sondern nur darauf hinweisen dass wir am,
ende dieses tages.
Genaue uhrzeit wissen wir noch nicht aber wir werden mit dem logbuch auf dieser konferenz vertreten sein und im roten salon laden.
Und wir freuen uns wenn ihr auf diese konferenz kommt und dann natürlich den weg in den roten salon
findet um dort gemeinsam mit uns was auch immer in dieser woche aktuell wichtig und gallig ist nochmal revue passieren zu lassen
und freuen uns natürlich auch danach auf geschützte hände und.
Party party party.
Party und bierchen und also was alle.
Alles also die npd dieses das ist netz politik trotz des eigenwilligen namens eigentlich immer eine.
Sehr schöne veranstaltung wie soll es auch anders sein wenn sie von der redaktion von netzwerk couragiert wird der gehört er natürlich davon ausgehen dass es dort ein.
Ja cutting edge programm geben.
Jetzt programm aber vor allem und das war ja glaube ich auch von anfang an
dividende als die veranstaltung das erste mal stattgefunden hat und ja eigentlich so als geburtstagsparty erstmal gedacht war dass es sich wiederholen muss
mit abstand die höchste dichte von allen leuten die in irgendeiner form weiteren sinne netz politisch let's politisch und überhaupt politisch auch,
aktiv sind das heißt wenn ihr schon immer mal mit dem gedanken gespielt habt euch in diesem feld.
Ein wenig mehr einzubringen oder etwas einzubringen habt dann solltet ihr ohnehin mal erwähnt hat vorbeizukommen naja und diesmal eben auch mit politik keine große gala ganz normale sendung vielleicht mit der ein oder anderen.
Kalt oder so so jetzt drehst du schon wieder auf auf jeden fall mach mal und freuen uns wenn ihr da seid.
Und tschüss sagt das hat und wir sagen tschüss und zwar jetzt.
Tschüss.
Weil sie nur war lange noch.
Das ja weg jetzt.
Danke danke sagen danke danke.
Danke danke lukas christian georg ihr seid spitze vielen dank tschüss jetzt hier tim aus kommen weg jetzt.
Jawohl bis bald.